I'd seen it in 3d and it is amazing um  because they've certainly used the  effect of that to bring you an immerse  you in the world but in imax it was as  if you were just in that world person i  think any film deserves being seen in a  theater but especially a film in which  the spectacle itself is such a character  and the world i mean it's the world of  warcraft it's called that for a reason  saving the world was not a one-man job  it's huge and it's epic having that  immersive experience is really gonna add  another layer to the film if you're  watching it on your little screen it's  great but if you're watching in imax  it's it's something else whatever you  plan to do do it now I'm always  mesmerized by the sound of I'm it I'm  always so impressed cuz that's the thing  that gives you that washroom its massive  and its perspective you have I felt as  if you are really on a ride it was  unlike anything had ever experienced  before  you